just have a look at this massive wooden
door behind me the decorations on it the
shiny marble and the number of security
guards behind my shoulder there you have
it will tell you that we're inside the
wall palace of the Saudi King the venue
for the first visit of the Russian
president in more than a decade to this
country however when mr. Putin just
arrived the whole event began with a bit
of an embarrassment for the orchestra
that was welcoming him
[Music]
[Applause]
however when President Putin stepped
inside the world palace it was clear
that the saudi side tried to do their
best to make sure that mr. putin feels
like he's at home here and the royal
residence and that was reflected through
the things that the two leaders set to
each other once they sat down in the
so-called blue hall I hope this visit
would be very productive and then we'll
continue this cooperation between our
countries bilateral ties between Saudi
Arabia and Russia have progressed in
numerous areas and we consider Russia to
be our friend Russia pays a lot of
attention to its deepening bilateral
ties with Saudi Arabia our bilateral
ties were established over 90 years ago
in 1926 the Soviet Union was the first
foreign country to recognize the young
Kingdom we value your efforts to boost
our ties the room was obviously full of
all kinds of government officials and
the wealthiest entrepreneurs from both
countries this is how much Riyadh and
Moscow want to do business with each
other but they're also up for sorting
out the issues that are troubling the
Middle East nowadays just a little
earlier I walked along the streets of
Riyadh and looked into the main things
on the agenda of the leaders of Saudi
Arabia and Russia this Monday
[Music]
Saudi Arabia and Russia is a remarkable
example of how two countries could be
great partners or friends and foes at
the same time everything that riad gets
itself involved in in the Middle East be
it about Iran Yemen or Syria gets full
support from Washington and you do
realize that in all these cases Russia
is on the different side of the
barricade
[Music]
but when the Russian leader and the
Saudi Crown Prince get along so well in
person by the way they are the authors
is probably the most famous high profile
high five in the world the chances that
the dialogue could work will always be
very high
[Music]
I have very good relations with both the
king and the crown prince we have been
making good headway practically in all
fields surely we do have to bear in mind
that the two countries are the world's
largest oil producers are they
competitors no in this case most likely
OPEC plus partners too so all kinds of
oil gas and issues related to the energy
sector are on the agenda especially
after the drone attack from last month
on one of Saudi Arabia's most important
or refineries which cook the country's
output by almost a half and almost put
the region on the brink of a real crisis
[Music]
Yemen's Houthi rebels said we did it
Washington and allies almost immediately
blamed it all on Tehran it was feared
that a us-led strike on Iran could have
been imminent the incident even led to
Vladimir Putin suggesting that Saudi
Arabia whose army is almost totally
dependent on arms imports from the US
should buy Russian made air defense
missile systems it's another chance for
mr. Putin to sell those but even without
them two billion dollars worth of
contracts are expected to be signed
between Moscow and Riyadh
[Music]
you